alphy we left your character on a bit of
a cliffhanger in season 2 and season 3
has been full of mystery now I know you
didn't know exactly where it was going
with Theon so what did you think when
you got that script for season 3 well I
wondered if the writers hated me but
knows it was good it was a it was a bit
daunting because I didn't really know
where to draw on from that sort of from
that much pain but it was a it was an
adventure and it was an exciting
adventure but it was our hard adventure
for sure shooting that third season how
was it been on that rack because you
were significant a few hours of you
filming on that wall that the rag rag
yeah it was getting me good no not
really it was it was challenging it was
it was fun and you know just to be able
to work with someone like you and me on
so closely was was a pleasure and long
may it continue who knows but mostly
we'll see what happens with that
relationship it's a it's just a great
working with talented people and to have
such a sort of interesting complex
storyline it's great now we've seen him
get pretty brutally stuffy this season
over you and he's a bit of a cruel
character to say the least you think he
can get even crueler we've seen the
worst of him yet oh I don't know I mean
I'm sure in the game of thrones world
anything can get cruel like on it but
but yeah we'll just have to wait and see
whether where he gets cooler or nicer
boom I'm sure he will get cooler and
nicer but in really effed up ways so
we'll just we'll just wait and see what
happens luckily he's one of those kind
of characters listen dear we had a
little bit of a chat to him the other
night at a special screening for phone
call the big wedding and we asked him
who he thought was worse Joffrey or his
character and he said Joffrey no what do
you think about that as beyond oh I
would have to say I would have to say
Joffrey as well yeah because I think
it's harder to put yourself in Joffrey's
shoes as a character to relate to
because everything he does is I mean for
me as a character I say it's easier to
relate to to to the boy because
heeey there's some things that I know
about in which audience members won't
that you can relate to but I would say
in a weird way he's a slightly more
human character than Joffrey and so yeah
I would say that I would say the Joffrey
is more of a mean person than him I bet
she'an doesn't think that right at this
moment though yeah no I don't think he
even knows he even remembers who Joffrey
is at this point he's as though this guy
all this stuff going on is boy yeah
exactly
I think he's a pretty he's in a pickled
state of mind in the moment for sure he
had quite an arc hasn't he Theon since
you first met him you had the whole
story of his sister as well he's also
gone from being a trickster with
everything that happened at Winterfell
and pretending that he's killed bran and
Rickon too weak the tricked hasn't he
how's that been completely yeah it's um
it's great it's just good good to sort
of um get get your head around but it
was a yeah he it feels kind of like bad
calling it a trick with the two kids
because everyone gets so riled up about
it they're you murdered two children
it's a it's a it's an awful thing but I
had to be honest with you I always
thought Theon would enjoy playing the
trick on the village more more than more
than feeling sort of sorrow for it but
yeah it's uh it's it's yeah it's
interesting that he sort of been the
trickster so to say and now he's just
being duped every single opportunity
that he can be duped at I think we've
got a chance of redemption for Theon on
the show in India in its in its in the
hands of the writers depending on where
they want to go with it but we'll just
see what happens who knows if you like
to see him safe do you think he could be
saved I mean in your opinion what have
saved in situation he's in also safe and
kind of some of the things that he's
doing yeah
yes I think that there is a waiting to
be saved from a sort of state of mind
but in terms of his situation I don't
think there's any saving happening now I
mentioned you are a your sister before
we spoken to Gemma Weiland no he played
there a few times lovely and she
obviously gave you a bit of advice when
she came to see theond and she at
Winterfell she said get out of there get
back home don't die so far from the sea
yeah you wishing you taking that advice
now haha yeah in a way it was a TV
honestly I don't think Theon was even he
was so dead set on just staying there
and making a point of thinking that he
was he was doing the right thing and
sticking by his decision even not really
not thinking about what his decision was
it was just about sticking by his
decision and so yeah I think I think
that he went when Jim when a Yara gives
him that sort of stuff about don't die
so far from the scene I remember when
you're a little boy it's just again it
leads him into making the wrong decision
because he's just so clouded by this
sort of history that he gets as a child
that he's never had in his life ever you
know he's never had that sort that that
sort of it that's what family history
you know that sort of like yearning for
a relationship of some sort with any
member of his family and she gives him
that in that ten seconds so he's
actually paying attention to what she's
telling him in the story rather than
saying don't stay here you know so he's
so intent and so just crazed
power-crazed at that point that he just
wants to stay in that situation that he
doesn't actually heed her advice at all
he's just listening to what there is in
the story rather than what the story is
meant to be telling him do they mean
some do you think if you see or
hopefully when you see you are against
it mean you got out hopefully and that
she'll say
tarji so hopefully I mean what no flee
yeah I mean it does one yeah I think I
think any good member of her family
would would what would do that I told
you so
so yeah it's what members families tend
to do don't they yeah reconciliation I
guess it has to go on there as well if
you do see her and also with your dad as
well that's not been the top
relationship ever has it no it's an
interesting one but you know sort of
relationships with the with the family
it's universal isn't it you know
everyone can relate to that so it's um
it's interesting we just see what
happens in it when you mentioned working
with you before what's it been like
working with Gemma as well and of course
Duke Patrick malahide he had as well
with you playing your dad balon greyjoy
very good with me and Patrick I sort of
decided not to sort of speak to him that
much and didn't really bond with him
that much because I wanted there to be a
sort of uncertainty between us and I
think he got that he understood in
binney's if he's a veteran you know he's
I he's a legend really so he knows
exactly what he's doing and he just let
me go on with it let me do my thing and
Gemma is just a joy like she's very
she's you know she's a comedian at heart
so yeah she's very very funny to be
around and um and yeah she's just it was
great sort of building up some as
chemistry with her it was very cool I
mean your or Theon's reputation as a
ladies man got him into a little bit of
Trevor potential Trevor didn't it when
he first met your and what do you think
when you read that script to start with
um it was great I mean I just I I just
thought it was a just showed how sort of
small the the Yarra is in a way and how
I'm sort of foolish Theon can be at
times you know um but yeah I thought it
was uh it was dark but it was a bit in
there in a sort of situation in which is
sin it's not dark because no one is any
wiser to the situation at that point so
it's just people Theon isn't
and so what Yara does ISM is a
dedication to how how how much she wants
that information from him and how much
she can take a hold of the situation and
how much more of a leader shoes than
Theon really it's a lot of feisty
females on the show actually on stage of
running theme with Game of Thrones
there's a I think somebody wrote an
article recently that's been sort of
banded about quite a lot where a woman
said girls don't like Game of Thrones
because it's such a macho show and it's
so how can you say that when there's so
many strong female roles in it it's a
running theme in it almost the strong
females in it you know so it's some
stupid thing to say for that without
that journalist to say but but yeah
definitely it's a running theme in end I
think Gemma Yara is one of them is one
of the most likable sort of females in
it I think sure she's got skills as well
hasn't she you've got skills as well as
a bit of an archer because you say bran
don't you early on Howard's weapon
shooting her far haha you're not so good
with a sword they are you when it came
to I know yeah I know well you know it's
um all sort of shows a lot about the
character but he's when I saw that scene
I couldn't wait to do it was so excited
to it was great it was just um just a
really horrible dramatic epic scene I
mean on paper you know hopefully that's
when it came to fruition on on the
screen but when I read it I was just so
excited to do it and it was just so I
think a lot of people were very sort of
blown away by and taken by so I hope it
will carry through I guess as well that
contrasts with how Rob did the same job
as well yeah exactly you did it very
cleanly very efficient
good old Rob you would like live
annuities day wouldn't know he wouldn't
well I mean he brings a little bit a bit
proud of him but at the same time yeah
he he would be a comparing for sure
there's been some amazing deaths on the
show having there which one of you kind
of didn't we've liked and enjoyed it is
the right word but it stood out view in
particular and and if you had to die on
the show how would you like to go out in
a striking manner I'd like to just go
very quickly very non painfully high
probably not some of the stuff that
you've been doing so far this yeah
exactly but yeah I I would like him to
be air to go vote non painfully and very
quickly and what was the other which
which are the deaths have stood out for
you could have been so many how about
there's so many amazing one mister
mister head of the family that I am sort
of meant to be part of that was pretty
pretty crazy early the unexpected
totally and which ourselves death has
been great I really liked moderate
Cassell's death because I killed him
that's good house good death uh yeah and
then God who has whose deaths have been
great I really liked it when mister
company sakes I feel like a ruining of
people but somebody's hand gets chopped
off that's pretty cool but that's not
really a death Jaime Lannister's hang at
shopper's we seen that already don't
worry about okay yeah but you never know
people are still catching up oh do you I
mean or it could grow back could you
could go back yeah exactly
Jaime Lannister the worm
but yeah I think that's I mean we have
probably mr. head of the family who in
the first series yeah I think that's
probably the best one you open your
favorite moments to see on so far
favorite moment is Theon for me
has probably been the the the speech in
episode 9 in deficit n so the second
series that was good I enjoyed that yeah
and it makes me laugh so when I see when
I seem to get knocked out it makes me
laugh it's funny it's very funny adds a
lightness to it and it you know yeah
just like the fact that people might be
rooting for him slightly but not knowing
why because they hate him but yes I
think that was probably my favorite
moments do nicely chats Dogma and all
those guys are they who dank married all
those guys they're not nice to him are
they they're not nice ball so no no I
mean dead a nice to him on a pretense at
first but then yeah when they figure out
that he's not really the commanding type
then they take full advantage of them do
you think they might be back at some
point or just think do you think senile
get his vengeance I'll that'd be good to
say if you like to see so many hope so
yeah I mean we'll have to wait and see
but but I would I would love to see them
I'd love to see there they'll be great
would you like to see at the end of the
day on that iron throne a year you're
gonna be a House Stark sill or a team to
garyun I am I'd like to see I are on
phone yeah I is really cool chick and
yes I'd like to see aya and then in who
else would I like to see you Braun
I like Brahmas character as well Ron
would be cool on the Ron vehicle king of
thing Ron would be a really cool kid so
I'm solving the robber Ratheon mold I
think maybe he might mold into that sort
King baby fun wouldn't he he would be
fun but I think I'd have a bit more
control over it maybe the Rope ruffian I
think you'd play the game a bit more
- no good power corrupts power corrupts
it's very true a lot don't we exactly
totally and not just in going with Rome
a day totally I mean you know the world
of Game of Thrones in the first series
is really about the politics of the land
everyone ends up stabbing each other in
the back which is true to life in
politics
exactly I heard this a bit of pranking
goes on on set as well I heard there's a
few things with text messages and Frank
screw it so tell me a bit about that
well I got a prank script it says it in
the book that was released and I had got
prank scripts that said I basically got
the script through that said I was I was
killed by brand and throughout the
second series because in the third
series I'm writing it that much oh it's
all really in in the books rather and I
I was always asking David and Dan I was
a time out my Indian I don't mean to
know I was always on tenterhooks I
didn't really know it was going on and
and yeah they they sent me a script
through I read it on the way back on the
plane I thought it was brilliant thought
what what a way to go man what a way to
go people remember that you know I just
look brilliant to be killed by a child
and such a great character as bran and
then and then I was on it on the beach
in Ibiza I got phone call from Dan going
so how do you like your ending was it
good nose like yes great for decimal
okay like what do you think webbing is
aam be for the next series what about
that that was like the spray goes
fantastic this Britain okay what do you
think about being an e kids are be now
is I know they're like what do you feel
of being a naked zombie with absolutely
no dialogue whatsoever you don't talk
you don't say anything you just wander
around in that knows that this is a
wind-up isn't it you're winding me up
you're winding me up no like yeah I have
Chris room [ __ ] way anywhere so yeah
it was funny yeah they're pranksters but
that sort of sort of makes it such a
family atmosphere on set it's great
is that kind of sleep through then you
think into how everyone feels and cuz
you've got dark storylines but it kind
of still keeps things a bit light
oh for sure yeah I mean just a general
vibe of just being on the showi is quite
you know like I said it's a big family
and it's a light atmosphere so when
those dark things come it's um it's much
easier what are you looking forward to
about season 14 because are so glad
always think how could it never have
been sure thing but I'll be sitting
confirmed now thank goodness what do you
like to see happen for anybody in season
four doesn't have to be the Theon or for
Thea I want to see more of Jaime and
Brienne I want to see more of that
they're brilliant I want to see more of
that and obviously I want to see more
Theon and and
and more Pete Dinklage as anyone would
ever want to see obviously and just more
characters with new characters I think
that's the best thing about this show is
that so many amazing new characters get
introduced every season and as an actor
just as a real person to get to meet
these people to what you had in your
mind is sort of work from where you read
as the books then see it come to real
life is really I love it so it's just so
easy I'm a big fan you know I'm a fan
and speaking of fans just finally a
message to the fans here watching this
video out there keep watching
we're gonna keep on striving to make it
better and better and it will only get
better embarr so just stick with it as
you would obviously but yeah just uh
keep with it man it's great it's
brilliant
we're gonna keep on making a better man
you